football is in mourning at Chelsea's
Stamford Bridge
at Everton's goodison Park Applause rang
out for one of their own
Christian atsu once dubbed the Ghanaian
Messi Rose from abject poverty to the
very top of the game playing for several
teams in England before moving to the
Turkish Super League
atsu had been missing since the
earthquake devastated Southern turkey on
the 6th of February his family had
gathered near his home in antakia but
after two weeks of searching their hope
ran out just one more death amongst tens
of thousands but no less keenly felt
across the footballing world it was a
lovely lovely person always smiling
always happy always is positive attitude
he worked really hard in the training
uh one of my favorite players
oh yeah
back in his native Ghana though radio
phone-ins remember more than just the
football of all the tributes that are
being paid to this guy
maybe about 10 percent are just about
his football Talent
it is telling and it's not that he was a
bad footballer
he was a very good footballer but 90 95
percent of things that are being said
about this guy
this is humanitarian work and that is
saying something I'm working with the
amazing charity arms around the child to
help build a new school in Saint
albrecha in Ghana he greeted everyone
with smiles and hugs and you know he was
just um he was a really really
passionate loving great it's a great man
you know he you know he was a you know
his husband he was a brother father
friend you know hero the kids absolutely
worshiped him at the the home that we
looked after
a young man with the world at his feet
his legacy will be defined as much for
his work off the pitch as on it Matthew
Thompson Sky News